thank you dog is out
so are we starting the live stream now
sonia
yes chairman um
ready to start when you're ready
all right thank you welcome to rockford
district council's remote audit
committee meeting
and welcome to anyone watching this via
this live stream
agenda item one apologies for absence
we have apologies from george ayano
and michael high
item two substitute members
i understand councillor wilson is
substituting for
councillor high three
non-members attending there are none
item four minutes of the meeting held on
the 28th of july
are the minutes agreed members
agreed agreed
agreed
we're all agreed
agenda item five
to receive declarations of interest
members are there any declarations of
interest
none
agenda item 6 financial statements for
2019-20
naomi lucas i believe the assistant
director resources will introduce the
report
thank you chair um yeah so
this um report summarizes
the preliminary audit conclusion um for
rochester district council's financial
statements for the year 1920
um i will hand over to um
debbie hanson who is the audit partner
and who's with us tonight um to go
through the substance
of um her report and her findings
um in just a moment um but i'd just like
to
to remind um members that the
draft accounts were published on the
council's website
um before the statutory deadline on the
25th of june 2020
and they have been available for the
public to view since that time
um the auditors have now
completed um the majority of their
their work um and they're able to give
the
preliminary audit conclusion for for
those accounts
um however there are still a couple of
matters that require final um
resolution and conclusion on their site
before the actual final accounts can be
signed off by the um chair of the audit
committee
um so for that reason we are um
asking for delegation for that final
sign-off to happen after the meeting
once those final matters have been
concluded
um on the assumption that there will not
be any material changes between
now and then if um for whatever reason
which is highly unlikely there were any
material changes the
we could bring another report back to
audit committee formally
but um because we're working to the
assumption that there's only minor
change um
only minor changes to the audit results
report that will be
required um yeah we will consider this
substance
of the accounts and and the auditor's
report tonight
um and then ask for that final
delegation to be given to the chair of
the audit committee to sign off once
they're ready
um members will also be aware that um
as a result of the covert situation this
year
the normal audit deadlines have been
extended slightly so
the final um deadline
when the accounts are meant to be signed
off and published is the end of november
so we're confident
that those um that that will um be
completed but by that that deadline and
we're hopeful that that will all be
completed by the
um probably the end of october so
um i don't think
there's anything um more i need to say
at this time but hopefully members have
had an opportunity to
to review both the accounts themselves
and the um the audit report that you've
got presented you tonight so at that
point i will
hand over to debbie to take you through
that report
thank you thank you naomi
thank you thank you if i could refer the
members
therefore to um the the report in the
pack
so our audit results report starts on
page 6.5
um which is actually just the cover
sheet um and then on the next page we've
got a letter which just sets out the the
status of the audit
um i think before getting into the
detail of the report um i just wanted to
highlight that i think this has been a
very successful
audit this year i think if members of
the committee will remember when we
presented the audit results report for
last year
we noted that there had been an
improvement in the quality of the
accounts and supporting working papers
last year and a reduced number of
differences identified i think this year
that positive direction of travel has
continued
we've only actually reported one audit
difference in our audit results report
which is a very
small difference which i will highlight
to you in more detail
so i really just wanted to take the
opportunity to say that particularly in
the difficult circumstances that we've
all been facing since march
um i think the process for the
production of the accounts and the
process to support our audit
um has been excellent and so and thank
you very much to the finance team for
all their support through that
as noah has said we have substantially
completed the audit and i will take you
through the areas that have still got to
be complete which are very much
administrative in nature
um and i'll just explain a little bit
more detail what they are and therefore
why we're not in a position to actually
sign off the accounts um
at this date if i can take members to
the executive summary which starts on
page
6.9 of your numbering
i wanted to highlight here to you some
of the changes
that we've had to make to our audit
strategy and following the issue of our
audit plan
back in july the main changes as you
would expect have been as a result of
ovid 19.
naomi's already highlighted the changes
to the reporting timetable
so i won't recap on that but then we've
also considered where kobit 19 could
have an impact on the financial
statements
and that's primarily in relation to
balance sheet items and also disclosures
within the accounts
and we've highlighted there two of the
initial ones that we identified which
was
the potential to um the council to
revisit the way it calculates the bad
debt provision because of the
possible greater default of people on
debts as a result again of the
impact on the economy from kobe 19.
we've also flagged the need for enhanced
disclosures ongoing concern
there is a presumption that local
authority accounts are always
prepared on a going concern basis
because there is a presumption of
continuation of service
so even if services were not provided by
rochester district council would
provided by another
entity and and basically a council would
only be dissolved by
an active parliament having said that
clearly the financial uncertainty
and going forwards has an impact on the
council and therefore we thought it was
important that the council enhanced that
disclosure
to make it clear what impact kevin 19
was having on its income and adventure
projections
uncertainties about future funding and i
think it's also important to note that
that assessment needs to look forward
and which is an unusual part of the
account so the rest of the accounts are
very backward looking
but the going concern assessment needs
to consider the council's financial
position
12 months from the date of the audit
report that's not from the balance sheet
day but it's from the date we actually
issue our opinion on when you approve
the accounts
in addition to that we undertake work
looking at the cash flow projections of
the council over that period
and i'm pleased to know that basically
following the council's enhancement to
its disclosures and provision of the
information to us
we're satisfied that it remains
appropriate for the accounts to be paid
on a going concern basis
and were satisfied regarding the
disclosures made in the accounts
i will come on to a little bit regarding
that on our internal consultation
processes in a moment
another area that we identified was
valuation of london buildings which are
included in the property plant and
equipment balances in the
council's balance sheet again an area
that was impacted by kovid 19
and as a result of the uncertainty in
the market ricks who were the the body
that sets the standards for property
valuations
issued guidance to value is highlighting
the impact of kovic 19 on markets
and noting that that may result in value
as concluding that the material
uncertainty regarding
that those that volatility and the
impact on their valuations
the all the value values that we've been
working with as part of our audit have
included a clause regarding that
material uncertainty in their valuation
reports
and the council has appropriately
disclosed that in its note on estimation
uncertainty
we've undertaken additional audit
procedures um to make sure that we're
satisfied
as of the council but the values in the
accounts are
materially and reasonably stated on an
estimation basis
and therefore we're satisfied that we
are there's no impact opinion and the
council has disclosed that
uncertainty appropriately
we also noted the need to consider
events after the balance sheet dates
clearly covered 19 itself and the
lockdown were post
sorry 31st of march and therefore not
post balance sheet events
however we did note that both accounts
and ourselves need to remain alert to
the risk that further events could occur
after the validity um relating kobit
90's
for example um key suppliers going into
liquidation could be an example
for some authorities and the council may
then need to consider disclosure
um i don't think there's been any
significant events um that have impacted
on russia that
required disclosure but clearly that's
something that's been kept under review
we also noted that in our plan we
referred to ifrs 16 which is a leases
standard
needing to be disclosed in the accounts
in terms of the potential future impact
again as a result of kovit 19 the
decision was made
by sipfer and mhclg to defer that
application of that standard for a
further year so therefore there was no
additional work required
in relation to that for this year
um the final few areas that we need to
note on are changes in materiality so we
always update our plan of materiality
once we get the draft financial
statements
this year we also considered whether the
materiality levels we'd set remained
appropriate in light of covid19
and that was really to consider whether
there was any change in the control
environment
any sort of broader increase of risk
across the board
we were satisfied that the levels we
previously set we made appropriate
at two percent of growth expenditure and
our performance materiality of 75
which is the level we use to actually
undertake our testing to provide
sufficient head room
um to make sure we don't miss any sort
of material error
another sort of quite practical area
impacted by kovid 19 is what we call
information provided by the entity um so
when we are undertaking our audit
procedures one of the things we have to
do
in relation to anything that the council
provides as part of the evidence of the
audit
is consider the completeness accuracy
and appropriateness of that information
um so any sense we're saying is that if
council's providers for example
an arrears report is that really an
arrears report as of the date we want
it does it include all the information
and is the information included within
it correct
there's a number of procedures we
perform around that and one of them is
quite often sitting with
officers as they run reports so we can
see that parameters being input
and make sure that report is actually
what we expect to see
and i think it's been very helpful that
we've been able to use the microsoft
teams
to actually share screens with with the
finance team and so that's actually
helped us in terms of addressing that
risk around
the ipe and then finally this is really
probably the key area that means we're
not in a position to be completing the
audit
today but we'll should be hopefully very
shortly is that
um ey along with all other audit firms
put in place first of all a moratorium
around signing opinions due to kobe 19
and then when that was lifted in
mid-april um it became clear that the
uncertainties and impact of kovid 19
still present a risk
both the accounts and the audit report
and therefore we put in place rigorous
consultation processes for all audit
reports that are issued
to make sure that we're providing
appropriate assurance the reading of the
accounts
that the disclosures in the council's
accounts are appropriate and that our
audit report
is also appropriate we are hoping to go
through that that sort of consultation
process fairly quickly
um but obviously we have not yet gone
through that and so
we're not in a position to issue the
audit report
the areas that we're consulting on or
considering consulting on a highlighted
on the next page
and so that's the uncertainty we've put
together valuers in relation to london
buildings valuations
and also the disclosures around going
concern
we have noted in this report that one
area we will be considering as part of
that is whether it's appropriate for us
to include an emphasis of matter
in our audit report to draw attention to
those two areas
of disclosure within the council's
accounts um
until we complete the consultation we
won't know whether that's required or
not at the moment i'm thinking it's
likely based on the work that we've
taken but we need to talk to confirm
that our
professional practice team is satisfied
that that's appropriate conclusion
i want to make it clear that an emphasis
of matter is not any sort of
modification or qualification of the
audit report
it merely draws a reader's attention to
something that we think is an important
disclosure in the council's financial
statements to help the
reader understand the financial
statements fully
so at the bottom of that page just above
the audit differences we've noted that
the
really the only areas to complete are
that internal consultation process
my final review of all of the audit work
and then obviously the receipt to the
signed accounts
letter of representation and famous
responsibilities so
all of the work of substance has been
completed which i think is a really
positive position to be in
if i then just refer you to the audit
differences at the bottom of that page
as i said
the financial statements were very well
prepared with very few issues identified
we've only got one unadjusted difference
that we identified of 130 000 pounds
which impacts on both income and
expenditure and overstates both of those
figures therefore has no impact on net
expenditure or the general fund balance
it relates purely to um recharges
between departments of the council
um in relation to housing benefits i
think i'm sure carrie will correct me if
members have any questions on that but
it's a very small difference that we've
identified that management
has got to adjust but we do ask that um
confirmation that the council is happy
for that not to be adjusted to be
included in the
representation which is signed when we
issue the audio report
the next page which is page 6.12 um just
highlights the risk that we've
identified in our audit plan
and then highlights our findings and
conclusions um i think
they probably speak for themselves
the only things really to draw to your
attention is first of all in relation to
the pension liability valuation
members may recall that we referred to
something called the mcleod judgment
last year which
impacted on accounts as a post-balance
sheet event
and there's now a further consultation
regarding the mcleod
um judgements um which again is a
post-balance event
we're satisfied that the impact that is
not material to rockford
but the council has included disclosure
in his accounts regarding that position
i think i've already covered all of the
other ones so i wasn't going to go
through those in any further detail
so i think what is the final page of our
executive summary on 6.13
we just know that we have not identified
any controlled differences as part of
our work that we need to
brought your attention and we've also
completed our value for money conclusion
work
and we did identify one significant risk
in our audit plan which was around the
council's asset delivery program
we finished our assessment of the
council's arrangements to deliver that
we've looked as part of that
of business cases they work with
specialists
counselors engaged to support them in
that and they're developing the strategy
and business case and we're satisfied
that those arrangements are adequate and
therefore we're proposing to issue
an unqualified value from any conclusion
alongside our unqualified opinion on the
financial statements
i don't think there's anything else i
was going to draw to members attention
the rest of the report just goes through
the risks in more detail
the actual audit procedures that we
undertook to address those risks and our
conclusions
it also includes an example of our audit
report or a potential audit report
the example that we've included does
include the emphasis of matter
and just so that members can see what
that would look like as i said i don't
yet know whether that will be included
in the final version of the audit report
or not
we then have a section that explains the
audit difference in a little bit more
detail
and the work we did around value for
money again in further detail
and at the end we have a section on our
independence
which also highlights the audit fee and
the proposed
audit fee in relation to the audit
as i said i think hopefully that gives
members an overview of the the key
issues as i said i think a very positive
result for the council
and definitely continues the um
direction of travel we reported last
year with very few issues identified
from the audit
i'm very happy to take any questions on
the report i should also say actually
that chloe
weaver is also on the call who's the
audit manager who actually managed the
delivery of the work rather than myself
thanks debbie so chair i would refer
back to you to
take any questions if there are any to
direct to either myself or to debbie
thank you
are there any questions
ah councillor lucas gayle
thank you chair um with
the effects of covid and
changes in market values do the auditors
uh see any possibility of the asset
development program
being badly affected
we didn't specifically look at that
aspect i don't think when we looked at
the values for money because the value
for money um assessment is looking very
much the council's arrangements up to
the 31st of march 2020
um obviously the council could not
foreseen kovid 19 therefore we weren't
really assessing
how the council might respond to that in
terms of his asset development program
i think it's a good question in the
sense that clearly it could because
there is such a lot of uncertainty
in relation to um assets at the moment
and part of the
the asset strategy is dependent on i
think disposal of
the council's assets that are kind of
not um surplus to requirements at the
moment so
clearly if depending on the market and
the type of those assets
and the value that the council is able
to obtain for the sale of those could be
impacted by kovid19
and i would think that would be
something we'd be looking at in our
value for money conclusion
for 2021 in terms of how you revisited
the asset management strategy to take
account of
of that volatility and uncertainty in
the markets but i think what we're
seeing is different
types of property are being differently
affected by kobig 19. so it very much
depends on the sort of makeup of the
sort of assets that the council have got
and the plans they've got for them and
how they are impacted but it's it's
certainly an area that i think the
council will be looking at
in 2021
thank you thank you uh
councillor sparing
your muted councillors bearing
councillor sparing you're muted
yeah can you hear me now chairman yes
thank you
yeah it's it's not so much a question
chairman but it's it's an observation
having been on the audit committee
along with some of my colleagues here
for a number of years uh
it's very very encouraging after should
we say in the past some
areas of concern we've raised for the
comments that debbie has
has raised or mentioned this time and i
think he's
you know a compliment to our own
financial team
for the strides they've made over the
last couple of years and and the
comments made this evening are very
encouraging thank you
thank you councillor sparing yes i i
totally agree with that
any further questions
no further questions yeah i have chair
oh that's the show uh yes
um obviously echo what has been said um
i think we've had a very challenging
year
well i think we're gonna have and it's
gonna go until next year so
it's a credit to um the audit team
and our officers for getting a good
report out
thank you
thank you councillor sean
doesn't appear to be any further people
wanting to ask questions
no no so we'll
we can go then um a paragraph
8.1 on page 6.3
there are four recommendations
recommendation 1 and 4 are for noting
recommendation one that the contents of
the draft audit results
report be noted and
recommendation for that the movement in
general fund balances be noted
our recommendations one and four noted
members
go to german noted noted
noted voted
right so i think that's that's agreed
so members can we please vote on
recommendations two and three together
are we happy with that agreed
i agree i agree
agreed right
number two is that the prince that the
financial statements be approved
in principle and number three
that final sign off of the financial
statements be delegated to the chairman
of the audit committee
subject to no significant audit changes
being identified
post the committee meeting i will assume
you are in agreement unless you click on
the raise hand icon
yes
so voting will be done by a roll call of
names
please indicate if you wish to have a
recorded vote and whether you are voting
for or against the recommendation
or if you wish to abstain
uh so so councillors you're voting um
for recommendations two and three um
uh counselor mrs butcher
four
answer mrs carter
thank you
answer lucas gill
cancel lucas jail sorry
the screen's playing up hey the vote is
for
thank you anselmeric
no recording pleasure and four
shaw no
wilson no and for
chairman that's unanimous
so that's uh the motion has been carried
unanimously thank you very much
everybody
well short and sweet that then concludes
the meeting
thank you for attending i'm closing the
meeting
at 19 56 p.m
thank you very much everybody and good
evening good night
thank you